whether they're meant to give us clues
about season three or to simply give us
all a reason to rewatch once we're done
with our first binge
here are some of the small details you
probably missed in the umbrella
academy's second season
spoiler warning for season two of the
umbrella academy
at the end of season two the time
traveling team successfully returns to
2019
only to learn the umbrella academy seems
to have been replaced with the sparrow
academy
apparently led by a not so dead ben i'm
just happy that we're home and
together again oh this isn't your home
these sparrows aren't the only birds
flying around the second season though
while you may not notice them before the
sparrow academy reveal the official
umbrella academy instagram page posted
that there are exactly 43 sparrows in
season 2
a significant number since there was
said to be exactly 43
super powered children born on october
1st 1989 in the show's mythology perhaps
the easiest example to remember is
harlan's sparrow toy
which we see him levitating in the back
seat of his mother's car towards the end
of the finale
in a light supper eagle-eyed viewers can
spot a sparrow logo on the piece of
paper the handler gives five with the
location of the commission's executive
board
a logo that mysteriously disappears when
five looks at it in the following
episode
other examples of sparrow logos show up
on the dairy truck the swedish assassin
steel
on the front door of the liquor store
that klaus visits on the room service
menu lila looks at
and on yet another on a piece of paper
in old man 5's briefcase
we haven't discovered them all yet but
the prospect of finding them isn't a bad
motivation to rewatch season 2.
one of the biggest surprises in the
season 2 finale is a crazy reveal that
lila is one of the super powered
children born in 1989
just like the seven members of the
umbrella academy similar to mimik of
marvel comics x-men
lila can use other people's powers to
her own advantage and we see her gift on
full display at the cooper's farm
while at first it looks like the academy
has slam-dunked the commission in the
season finale
lila is able to use their powers to even
the playing field how are you doing
oh anything that you can do i can do
better but what you may not realize is
this isn't the first time in this series
that she's used her powers at the end of
the episode valhalla she fights five in
a factory and the melee ends with five's
foot on her throat and with a handler
revealing herself
however three times during their fight
five expects lila to be one place and
she appears in another
initially we're supposed to assume she's
just unbelievably sneaky and fast but
when you re-watch the scene with the
knowledge of lyla's superpower it
becomes clear she's mirroring 5's
teleportation the camera isn't on her
when she uses it
so we never see the ripple effect thus
keeping her power a secret until the big
showdown
in the swedish job we get a quick look
at an unnamed character who's a pretty
clear reference to one of the most
acclaimed graphic novels of all time
watchmen just after luther starts off on
a morning jug outside his rooming house
an elderly man carrying a placard
reading the end is nigh appears and
starts walking in the opposite direction
so what's the reference here
well carrying up a card that warns of
the end of the world is just about all
the vigilante rorschach seems to do in
watchmen when he's out of costume
and while the man in the swedish job
doesn't look at all like rorschach with
his long hair and full beard he does
have a passing resemblance to alan moore
the author of watchmen
and it's a fitting reference for a
couple of reasons for one just as the
escalating tensions between the united
states and the soviet union provide
azimandiya's motivations and watchmen
it's an apocalyptic conflict between
these two superpowers that five is
struggling to avoid in the umbrella
academy
for another just like watchman's
ozymandias five employs some pretty
reprehensible tactics in saving the
world
like traveling to 1982 and assassinating
most of the commission's executive
board with an axe paving the way for the
handlers takeover of the organization
does it really matter now in the show's
first season we met pogo a sophisticated
chimpanzee butler with human
intelligence who was sadly killed by
vania if you've ever wondered about the
apes origin story the second season has
got your answers valhalla opens with a
flashback of the younger pogo as part of
an early project to see how chimpanzees
would be affected by spaceflight
and by extension what might be in store
for human pilots
and two episodes later in ugga for ugga
there's an easy to miss detail that
could point to pogo being much more
famous than you realized
when five travels a 1982 wisconsin to
kill the commission's executive board
he stops at a vending machine for a
candy bar the one he winds up with is
called a fudge nutter
but right next to that bar is one called
pogo gogos and above the name on the
wrapper it reads
take flight with it's a small detail but
it saves a lot
for pogo to have a candy bar named after
him suggests the intelligent chimp was
much more of a space age icon than we
realized
in the season premiere while all the
members of the umbrella academy arrive
in the same place they don't arrive in
the same year
oh they're gone they're gone
like a stark witch
they fall from the portal into the same
dallas alley one at a time or two in the
case of klaus on the ghost of ben
between 1960 and 1963. interestingly
right across the street from the alley
is a movie theater
and in at least three cases the theater
marquee is advertising a very specific
kind of movie
when klaus and the ghost of ben appear
in 1960 the marquee is advertising the
1959 film curse of the undead
as alison arrives in 1961 the theater is
apparently caught up with its releases
and the marquee announces that years the
curse of the werewolf the marquee during
luther's arrival in 1962
isn't really visible enough to read but
the same film is playing during diego's
appearance in 1963 when vanya shows up a
month after diego
and when five arrives in november 1963
the kiss of the vampire
of course in five's case the fighting
between the us and soviet forces have
blown most of the letters off the
marquee and we doubt the theater is
still selling tickets at that point
it may be that the marquees are meant to
reflect their heroes collective doubt
expressed throughout the season
about whether or not they're heroes
super powered freaks or as the marquees
reflect
monsters in other words it's not exactly
the kind of thing you want to see when
you're suddenly lost in the past
and struggling with self-esteem issues
in the umbrella academy comics the
hero's hometown is left intentionally
ambiguous
in fact it's referred to only as the
city but it looks like season 2 of the
series has revealed the location of the
academy's hq
at least as far as a tv adaptation is
concerned in a flashback in valhalla
we learn that as soon as he could luther
gets on a greyhound burst in the hopes
that he can find his father
during the trip there's an overlay
revealing the buses progress on the map
showing that luther gets off somewhere
in or around indianapolis it's an
interesting choice for a superhero hq
maybe the writers simply didn't want yet
one more superhero team hailing from the
big apple
maybe it just seemed far enough away
from dallas to be a long trip but not
too long
or maybe reginald hargreaves is a big
basketball fan and just wanted to be
near the hoosiers
when it comes to powers diego has a
pretty unique skill set the dude is a
master of knives
able to make bladespin through the air
with the greatest of ease and fly in any
direction he chooses
in the season finale however diego uses
his powers in a way that we've never
seen before
when the commission's goons are firing
on him and five diego buys five the time
he needs to make it to the house by
jumping out from behind cover
and stopping the hail of bullets mid-air
alan neo from the matrix
speaking to den of geek showrunner
stephen blackman said that this is an
extension of the powers we've already
seen before
explaining if you think about diego's
power he can with his mind
control the trajectory of objects
basically he likes throwing so he can
throw his knife
and he can make it go in weird odd
curvatures and directions
blackmon went on to say that the
aftermath of ben's death hurt the
chances that most of the members of the
umbrella academy
would reach their powers full potential
early on and that fans should expect for
the heroes to keep learning more about
their abilities
everybody wants to see powers all of a
sudden looking back on season 2 we've
already seen some of that
for example before season 2 klaus has no
idea it's possible for a ghost to
possess him and when spectral cowboys
save him from falling in the season
finale
he seems as surprised by it as anyone
else likewise even before she lost her
memory
vania had no idea she could use her
powers to resuscitate someone as she
does with harlan after he drowns all
that doing so would transfer her powers
to him
with every episode the umbrella academy
grows stronger and stronger
and we can't wait to see what weird
directions that powers will go
one of the potential differences between
the umbrella academy show and the comics
is that in the source material
diego has the ability to hold his breath
indefinitely
so far we haven't seen the power
expressing the tv series
or have we a reddit user going by the
name high arcanist
noticed something strange in a funny
scene in a light supper the academy
members all cram into an elevator on
their way to meet with their father
nobody is exactly looking forward to the
meeting and at least one of the heroes
is especially anxious
drawing the trip up almost everybody on
the elevator reacts in surprise and
disgusts as
we soon learn luther experiences some
unpleasant flatulence but there's one
person who doesn't react as negatively
as the rest diego
while everyone else is scowling and
covering their mouths and noses
diego is smiling seeming amused at the
whole thing at no point does he seem to
be suffering
from the stench as his brothers and
sisters are the high arcanist believes
it's because the diego of the show
shares the breath-holding ability of his
comic book counterpart and so he's able
to avoid most of the negative aspects of
the experience
and enjoy the discomfort of his adoptive
siblings it certainly seems possible
though it could also be that diego just
has a stronger stomach for his brother's
nervousness
in the seven stages five enlists
luther's help to do something that he
warns is very dangerous
to contact an earlier version of himself
doing this five warns is incredibly
risky because of what he calls paradox
psychosis
which is a kind of psychosis a person
may undergo when encountering themselves
in another time
there are seven stages of paradox
psychosis and we watch both five and old
man five go through all those stages
you just itched your neck that stage
psychosis
then i was stage one it's possible we
see someone else go through them earlier
in the season
two of the seven stages are excessive
gas and homicidal rage
and in a light supper we see luther
exhibit both on the elevator and at
dinner with their father
look at what you did to me
look at it and that kind of anger
especially directed at his dad is pretty
unusual for our hulking hero
blackmon is said to expect things in
season 2 to hint toward the future
could it be that another luther maybe
one from a future season is lurking
somewhere nearby
of course that would lead to the
question of why he isn't exhibiting the
other symptoms
although it could be that wherever the
future luther is hiding perhaps he isn't
as close to the 1963 luther as the fives
were to each other or for quite as long
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one